johann lava is taking a journey into the
past he's been interested in food and
the world of cooking since he first
started visiting the farmers market in
graz 40 years ago and he began when I
discovered here was just phenomenal it
inspired me and I love seeing people
like her who run their own farms and do
it all on their own you had to halt in
language of the mangas Alice some of the
vendors here remember laugher from way
back Friday remembers me guess I've been
coming here since 1972 yeah yeah I on CT
1972 was when I started at the goose
avoid that same year genova yeah time
flies today everyone here knows him
gerber locals are not you're not a soul
a robot magna a tenner at the Graz opera
even greets lover with a spontaneous
serenade I'm a huge fan after Arnold
Schwarzenegger Johan lava is cross his
most famous local celebrity but his own
success came as something of a surprise
his first years as an apprentice and the
goose of Roy tavern were anything but
promising
CST hobby hobby new kudos people the
first six months all I did was clean the
refrigerator peel potatoes and cut
onions for goulash just imagine what a
young kid the monotony of its fevered an
onion cut another onion it's enough to
drive you enough nevertheless he gladly
revisited his old digs boys table over
there somewhere and that's where i went
through endless sacks of devices sake
cut me off eight hours why's that 1214
hours at a stretch as he helped extreme
I'm big I was so homesick at first hurry
told us I was practically just a kid
really my man is yet Kwazii no fuss King
homesick for the village of san steffan
27 kilometers southeast of Graz Johan
lafa was born there in 1957 and grew up
with two sisters in the family home
his mother was his first teacher this is
an Iron Chef t-bird passion and love for
food and cooking that's what did it yeah
I do love cooking oh yeah you can i'll
never forget her jellyroll cake couldn't
have any cracks at the top or should be
pair of sacks guns [ __ ] laude
and to this day his mother schnitzel is
still the measure of all things for lava
and his sister Christina
and he happy foosh peacock I've cooked
for George Bush Mikhail Gorbachev Guinea
prima cough all kinds of people I've
been around the world today I couldn't
tell you what I cooked for Bush but I
remember the taste of my mother's
schnitzel and not just the taste but the
emotions the memories feeding the pigs
and the slaughter hiding under the bed
covers and on Sundays we had the best
piece of meat newest owned ice caps a
space issue flash
so it's hardly surprising that Johann
Navas primary culinary principal is
using locally grown products whose
origin he knows and he has a weakness
for him sent out a dream the aroma for
me it's awesome I just want to stay here
as a here mighty flame
today lava might be selling ham at the
farmers market in Graz if he hadn't
discovered a passion for cooking near
the end of his apprenticeship
had the anxiously I had a life changing
experience each februari here they put
on what's called the hearing schmaus a
big elaborate buffet I noticed there
were really nice dishes that cooking
wasn't just about peeling onions and
cleaning the fridge in God's my truck
partying God's looked around discovered
it was fun and that I had a talent for
us so I said that's the life for me to
keep cooking and hopefully be successful
not long afterwards lafa left Graz and
headed for Berlin and Munich there he
quickly found success but historian
roots influence Johan lava and his
cooking to this day
you